However, there could be some potential negative effects with people using
psilocybin. Could you touch on perhaps some unusual experiences?
&gt;&gt; Yeah, so it's very important to understand that there are risks, very real
risks, associated with exposure to psilocybin. So in our studies at Johns
Hopkins in, in a therapeutic context and when we are doing studies in healthy
volunteers. We very carefully screen our volunteers. We develop rapport with
them. The drug is given under very tightly-supervised and supportive context,
and we do after-care with them. why do we this? So, the reason that we do this
is because unfortunately psilocybin can produce some, some very difficult long
lasting, and potentially harmful effects. So, number one is that, under the
influence of psilocybin, people can have panic or fear reactions, and they can
end up engaging in dangerous behavior, and it's uncommon. But it's not unheard
of to read reports where people run out into traffic, jump out of windows, you
know, flee in ways that get themselves or other people into trouble. Two is
that there's, there really is concern, and this is more serious than just the
panic, there really is concern that in some individual. Exposure to psilocybin
and other compounds of this
[INAUDIBLE]
hallucinating class can precipitate in during psychiatric illness. the, the
worst possible case would be precipitation of psychosis or schizophrenia of
someone who was already vulnerable to that disorder. And that, it, that's a, a
lifelong, irreversible disorder that is is disastrous for someone. Other than
that there are some people who report persisting PTSD-like syndrome depression
and anxiety disorders. So, we're very concerned about that and, and it's one of
the reasons we screen people very carefully and support them through these
kinds of experiences. We just recently have conducted, and are continuing to
collect data on an online survey asking people about the most difficult
experiences they've had with psilocybin. And what we're finding is that most
people are reporting experiences when it's isolated to their most difficult
experience, they're reporting experiences that are among the most difficult
that they've ever had in their lives. And very often, the single most
challenging experience, so there's nothing easy about these experiences. But
the the more sobering statistics out of this survey is that anywhere from about
3% to 10% of people are reporting persisting effects that look like some kind
of persisting psychological harmful consequence. So some of these people never
had been in therapy before and have sought out psychological counseling for
fearful reaction, or anxiety disorders, or paranoid after the session with
Silly Simon. And they attribute their seeking that out to the Silly Simon
session. about 6% of people report a decreased sense of well-being and, and so
while these compounds may have great therapeutic potentials, there are also
significant risks.
&gt;&gt; Right, right.